wir haben bereits wieder über 100.000
erstanträge auf asyl in unser blatt
übrigens das neunte mal in folge also in
den vergangenen jahren war das auch
schon der fall es kommen gerade und das
ist wirklich sehr sehr problematisch aus
weißrussland aus belarus viele menschen
zu uns weil der belarussische diktator
lukaschenko menschen einfliegen lässt
aus beispielsweise syrien aus dem
libanon menschen nach weißrussland
reisen lässt und die schickt er dann an
unsere außengrenzen sodass dann menschen
über den weg polen hier zu uns ins land
kommen und zwar vielfach menschen das
kann man auch sehen und auch hören das
sagen die menschen auch wenn man mit
denen dort spricht die da gerade
unterwegs sind das sind täglich einige
dutzend die da kommen das sind jetzt
schon über 4000 die gekommen sind in den
vergangenen tagen die sagen auch ja sie
fliegen eigentlich nicht von not und
verfolgung sondern sie erhoffen sich ein
besseres leben dh das sind
wirtschaftsmigranten das ist dann eine
einreise die man eigentlich unterbinden
muss migration ja auch ein thema in den
sondierungsverhandlungen gewesen wird
auch im koalitionsvertrag erscheinen was
es da eine forderung an die politik wenn
man müsste ich jetzt eben tatsächlich
sehen wie schafft man ist das einzuhegen
also wer vor krieg und verfolgung
tatsächlich flieht dem wollen wir helfen
wir wollen aber nicht jedem helfen der
kommt und behauptet dass er vor krieg
und verfolgung fliegt das heißt die
politik muss hier sehen dass wir einen
klaren grenzschutz an der außengrenze
haben und dass wir auch mit blick auf
den diktator lukaschenko dass wir nicht
erpressbar sind und ihn entscheiden
lassen wir in unser land kommt sondern
das muss die eu und das muss deutschland
ich war gerade sagen lukaschenko gemacht
hast ja nicht ohne hintergrund dass er
die menschen einfach durch lässt was
glaubst du was will er im endeffekt
damit erreichen naja das ist im grunde
eine art rache aktion wegen der von der
eu verhängten sanktionen gegen sein land
das dürfen wir natürlich nicht zulassen
so etwas
[Musik]